bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation d'abord on va apprendre
de vos nouvelles puisque vous avez été
contaminée par le coronavirus à la mi
mars
comment allez vous aujourd'hui voilà
maintenant ça va il ya encore des petits
coups de barre mais c'est bien j'ai
repris une activité normale on va pas
dire ça puisque les cabinets sont à
moitié vide on travaille à peu près à un
peu moins de 50% d'une activité
habituelle mais c'est bon ça va je pense
plage m'en suis sortie je suis un peu
fatigué je pense que la fatigue va durer
encore un petit peu mais c'est bien
lorsque sortit alors vous avez suivi
donc cette polémique autour des mac
cette question est-ce qu'il faut oui ou
non porter un masque
est-ce que c'est utile c'est maintenant
c'est maintenant évident si vous voulez
qu'on sait que cette ce virus peut être
totalement asymptomatiques que les gens
peuvent être tout à fait contaminants en
n'ayant absolument aucun symptôme aucune
fièvre aucune courbature il est évident
que quand les gens sortent ils devraient
sortir masqué
l'accord est là pour montrer qu'ils ont
été capables d'enrayer l'épidémie très
rapidement en masquant la population et
en faisant des tests a pratiquement à
tout le monde donc c'est la politique il
faut suivre
maintenant il ya confites mans a été
décidée il faut il faut respecter ce
confinement parce que c'est la seule
façon maintenant de d'enrayer le
développement est d'éviter que les
services hospitaliers sont soit soit
complètement débordé en réanimation on
voit que on est obligé de transférer de
du grand test ou d'île de france vers la
province
en espérant que la vague n'atténue pas
la province alors on voit que martin
plus confinement est bien avancé le
discours officiel il a changé puisque
même au niveau de l' oms on conseille de
porter des masques en france également
on a entendu le directeur général de la
santé pourquoi est ce qu'on nous a
raconté alors au départ c'était inutile
finalement de porter des masques basse
et s était incontestablement une erreur
il était en train de gérer la pénurie il
savait quel était l'état des stocks et
l'état des stocks était bien plus faible
qu'on ne le pensait même quand on
commande vous savez quand on commande un
milliard de masques un milliard de
masques pour 60 millions de français ça
fait jamais que 15 masques par par
français si vous estimez que même en
l'utilisant très bien un masque c'est ça
dure quatre heures
bon bah il faut - il faut mois deux à
trois masques par jour et par français
donc c'est vite épuisé un milliard de
masques
donc j'espère que la production
française va suivre maintenant et et
qu'on n'aura pas se battre sur les
tarmacs chinois pour récupérer les
masques ont été commandés
alors vous pointez cette erreur autre
question encore puisque c'est vrai que
c'est difficile de s'imaginer dans ce
cas de figure cette pandémie cette crise
sanitaire mondiale
mais on sait en tout cas que le
coronavirus était déjà présent en chine
depuis plusieurs mois est ce qu'on
aurait pu anticiper justement ce manque
de masquer ses il est clair il est clair
que d'autres
de toute façon il n'aurait pas fallu
attendre la pandémie chinoise la
pandémie d'origine chinoise pour stocker
les masques on sait depuis quinze ans
qu'on est à la merci de de pandémie il
ya eu cette pandémie
il ya eu cette pandémie comment en 2005
ce risque de pandémie avec 7
avec cette commande venir grippe aviaire
il ya eu ensuite la la grippe h1n1 qui
est une pandémie qui heureusement a fait
flop en 2009 mais on sait qu'on est à la
merci d'une pandémie mondiale et le
moindre
la moindre des choses pour un
gouvernement c'est d'avoir des stocks de
masques qui protège les gouvernants et
puis qui protège également les français
on a vu que la corée qui a masqué
quasiment toute sa population a réussi à
endiguer la l'épidémie alors on nous
raconte maintenant cosin allemand et
essai c'est normal on comprend que les
masques ffp2 sont réservés au personnel
soignant qui sont en contact direct avec
les malades
mais on nous dit qu'on peut utiliser des
masques alternatifs parce que c'est
efficace ou pas est-ce que ce serait
efficace beaucoup plus efficace on en
doute en tout cas que porter un masque
ffp2 mais vous savez nous l'a par
exemple on a une remplaçante qui est
d'origine taïwanaise et quand sa famille
a su que on était on n'était pas équipée
on vient de recevoir
avant-hier un carton de masque en tissu
qui sont de très bonne qualité qui qui
sont lavables et c'est masque en tissu
sont des masques anti-projections c'est
à dire que quand vous êtes dehors avec
ses masques là vous vous contaminer
personne et c'est ça qui compte
le l'université de grenoble je crois que
c'est le chu de grenoble qui a fait un
[Musique]
tutoriel pour pour fabriquer des masques
en coton je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui commencent à bricoler des
masques qui sont tout à fait efficace
justement des masques anti projections
et et quand vous sortez dehors masqué
vous ne contamine et personne et c'est
déjà une bonne chose
et alors sur l'évolution justement de la
pandémie en france on a quand même une
nouvelle encourageante je voudrais votre
réaction par rapport à cela
c'est le nombre d'arrivées en
réanimation même si c'est vrai que le
nombre d'essai ne cesse d'augmenter de
jour en jour oui et pour le nombre de
décès malheureusement il va il va
augmenter parce que il ya beaucoup de
monde en réanimation je crois qu'il ya
près de 6000 personnes en réanimation
bon on essaye de se raccrocher à tout
signe tout petit signe d'espoir on sait
qu'en italie ça ça continue malgré
malgré un cloisonnement malgré un
confinement sévère donc je pense qu'il
faut éviter de se réjouir il faut garder
l'espoir que on va réussir à contenir
cette épidémie mais il faut pas il est
encore trop tôt pour parler de
déconfinement même si on s'aperçoit
quand même qu'avec le beau temps on a vu
davantage de personnes sortir ces temps
ci il faut surtout rester chez soi à
respecter la distanciation sociale et
porter un masque quand on peut porter un
masque parce que c'est la solution
merci beaucoup jean paul eymond pour
votre regard sur cette crise sanitaire
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
la fédération des médecins de france
merci à vous